I was asked to give a set of readings
for you and I did and I am going to
assume that you have done or will do
those readings so I'm not going to talk
about what's in the readings okay I what
I'm going to do is is to to illustrate
the argument in the readings if the
readings are where they really focus on
the nature of the colonial state but I
want to talk a little more broadly about
the nature of the state in colonized
places particularly Africa when one
speaks about the nature of the state in
Africa there are certain presumptions
preconceptions one runs into and against
the most important presumption a
prejudice I would say because it's not
an informed view but the most important
one is the assumption that a organized
political power did not exist in Africa
before colonialism and if it did exist
then it must have been brought from the
outside in the study of Rwanda this is
known as the Hamitic hypothesis
this assumption is so widespread how
many of you have read Guns Germs and
Steel a a very interesting book but with
some problematic assumptions and the
Assumption on Africa in Guns Germs and
Steel is precisely this that there was
no organized political power in Africa
no indigenously indigenously organized
power prior to a external mainly
European presence on the continent the
second assumption the second assumption
is that the beginning of organized
political life the beginning of a
possibility of law and order is the
colonial period the third assumption
is that the reason for the proliferation
of ethnic conflict around the continent
after independence is that colonialism
ended too soon colonialism should
actually have continued and finished its
job
that's the third assumption these are
widely held assumptions
I'm not curry catering and and sometimes
they tend to be held or not even
consciously which is more serious deed
today currently in in the present day
American imagination the example of this
is Darfur right that's the example so
what I want to do today is to talk about
the state but in the very specific
context of Sudan and Darfur and I want
to talk about it historically I don't
know how long it will take but everybody
is allowed to vote with their feet if
mine give way I'll just sit down and but
I'll try and make a coherent argument
that's what I'm saying
okay so it will take a bit of time it'll
take an hour and something
take boy you're wondering why you asked
me to come it they wonder every year and
they ask me to come every next theater I
don't know why so that's what I'm going
to try and do now if you were if you
were in the University of Khartoum in
Sudan and you were studying history in
that university you would notice that
there is a big gulf between academic
history and popular memory Sudan by the
way is the largest country in Africa
right it's roughly a third of the United
States in its in its surface area and
Darfur is the size of France right on a
small place roughly if I don't know
about a third but a good chunk of Sudan
but size of roughly the size of France
so if you were at the University of
Khartoum and you were studying history
you would notice a gulf between academic
notions of history and popular memory
between what people like you educated
young person's your sense of history and
what the man and the woman in the street
the history that they identify with the
academic notion of history in the
university
would trace the history of Sudan to
about 6,000 years ago
to as far back as you can trace the
Pharaohs of Egypt because running
alongside the history of ancient Egypt
is the history of ancient Nubia periods
in which Egypt conquers Nubia but
they're also periods in which Nubia
Congress Egypt and then that history is
followed by centuries of the history of
Christian kingdoms in northern Sudan and
it is about round about 1650 fairly
recently in against the span of against
the backdrop of this 6,000 year history
round about 1650 did you get Muslim
Muslim kingdoms into that two major
Muslim kingdoms
the kingdom of funds with its capital
its Sanaa and the kingdom of Darfur the
Sultanate of that for the kingdom of
funds is the Nile Valley come down south
and Darfur is to the west on the chargin
border so this academic person would
have this long history in mind the
person on the street doesn't think of
ancient Nubia as part of the history of
Sudan for that person ancient Nubia is
maybe part of the history of a
particular group in Sudan the Nubians
they don't think of the Christian
kingdoms it's part of the history of
Sudan because for the northerners those
were Christian kingdoms what does it
have to do with us we are Muslims and
for the southerners the southern elite
which is predominantly Christian not
ordinary population but the elite which
is predominantly Christian even if there
were Christian kingdoms there were
northern kingdoms what does it have to
do with us for popular opinion in Sudan
the history of northern Sudan begins
with these two sultanates there are four
and five
16:50 on and this is a little earlier
but I'm going to concentrate on this
when the Sultanate of Darfur
at first I want you to get a sense of a
process of state formation in Africa
before colonialism this is way before
colonial right Sultanate of Darfur when
it begins 1650 the landscape is a series
of chiefdoms local small-scale to
Sultanate emerges amongst the four
people and its first problem
its first problem is how to how to
become autonomous of the chiefdoms and
then how to be a kingdom how to become
autonomous then how to dominate over the
chief doubts otherwise it will just be
another shift up how does it become a
Sultanate how does it become a power
over and above chiefdoms an overarching
power which first coexists with them and
then dominates over them and
incorporates them
initially the Sultanate has a moving
capital the King is afraid that the
provinces will secede unless he moves
camp from province to province you can
see it's like it still like a chiefdom
it's the establishment of a capital in
the early 18th century around 1710 in Al
fashio
today northern Darfur that signals that
the key institutions for a centralizing
power are in place so I want to begin
with the discussion of those
institutions what are the institutions
on which this centralizing power is
built the first institution
the first institution is a system of
landed estates landed estates this is
known as the hakura there are two kinds
of landed estates administrative and
special the administrative landed estate
is kind of a transitional phenomenon
meaning in part it's simply a
recognition of the reality that existed
but in part it's something new the
something old is that these
administrative hakura are landed estates
that the King purports to grant to
tribal chiefs and in granting it to
tribal chiefs all the king is doing is
acknowledging what they control that's
the old but the new is that the King
part of the grant of the hakura
is certain rights two kinds of rights
right of exemption from taxes and the
right to settle disputes and with the
administrative hakura these rights are
granted in part so the king can levy
some taxes some kinds of disputes will
have to come to court so the new part is
that the power of tribal chiefs is being
curtailed some of their power is being
acknowledged but some of it is being
transferred to the court
the second type of hakura special occur
is the grant of landed estates to
notables court notables and this the
dynamic element in the system these
grants are recorded in writing they are
there in museums hundreds of them are
there
historians read them and write about
them and these grants give more or less
full exemption from taxation and full
rights to settle internal disputes these
grants are almost akin to individual
property if the first is a quasi
representation of tribal property if the
administrative hakura is a quasi
representation of tribal property the
special Hakuba is almost individual
property I'm trying to give you a sense
of the dynamic element and how things
were moving as opposed to this notion of
traditional Africa but nothing changed
there's no history until some thing
happened from the outside
so that's the first institution now who
are these notables who got who got the
grants how did the court where did it
really the court get its officials the
first institution the court had to
create was an army had to create an army
and if you are in a terrain with tribal
chiefs where will you get the army from
and the solution is to create an army
from slaves right Darfur is an enslaving
power it enslaves to the south
southern slaves are brought to Darfur
some of them are exported the majority
remain in Darfur and they mainly go into
the army you have to keep in mind a
distinction between pre-modern and
modern slave trade there's a similarity
and a distinction the similarity is that
the capture is as brutal whether it's
pre-modern or model the wrenching
removal of the enslaved person from
their home but the difference is in
where the demand is coming from the
demand for slaves in the pre-modern
period came mainly from the state there
was domestic slavery but it was small
mainly from the state even the early
Roman Empire not the army but the
administrative structure recruited from
slaves because simply question of
loyalty where are you going to get
officials if you get them from the
chiefdoms you're not sure of royalty
slave is removed from his usually his
not her his home environment the one who
is going to become an official and for
questions of loyalty
so slaves could rise to the highest
positions tiny minority but they could
so the second group are royal slaves
royal slaves
who are in charge of sections of the
army and who are administrators court
officials who administer outlying areas
starting with pastoralists but then
agricultural is also the slaves become
so powerful in Darfur
you know usually in a state one of the
most difficult questions is that of
succession succession is the time where
everything can fall apart how do you
ensure successful democracies succession
is the time they bring in the population
the population doesn't rule simply gets
beside who rules alright
the idea that democracy is a government
of the people by that by the people is a
little bit of public relations but the
population comes in at the time of
succession who rules
18:03 is the last time there is a it's
the last time the question of succession
is decided on the battlefield in Darfur
after that it's decided by King makers
and the king makers are the leading
royal slaves the slaves who cannot rule
but who decide who will rule which of
the princes will rule
I just want to digress a little bit to
sort of clearly underline this point
because the slaves of Darfur are being
exported to Egypt in Egypt the Arabs
conquer Egypt from Byzantine 7th century
and the Arabs lose out within a century
they lose out there are succession of
dynasties and powers that come in the
first important power which comes in are
the Fatimids but the important thing is
after the Arabs every power that comes
in wants to marginalize the Arabs remove
them from the army and they create an
army from slaves slaves imported rival
dynasties import slaves from different
places the Fatimid import slaves from
the south nubian slaves they were called
Nubian wherever they are from in the
south the rivals import slave from
turkey the mum looks
Egypt is a place where the slaves come
into power the mum looks rule Egypt for
several centuries so we go back to
Darfur there are the royal slaves then
there is Islam the third institution is
Islam because the ideology of the new
centralizing power the kingdom the basis
for a new loyalty the ideology that will
provide the basis for a new loyalty a
loyalty that will counter kinship is
religion is Islam but Islam will not
simply provide a new basis for a new
loyalty it will also provide the
instruments of literacy because it will
go hand in hand with Arabic and literacy
will make it possible to have an
administration which is not simply a
face-to-face administration it will make
it possible to have an expanding
Sultanate as the Sultanate expands
by the time we come to the end of the
19th century only a third of the
subjects of the Sultan are for only a
third those who preach Islam known as
the folk or the holy men come mainly
from West Africa there are pilgrimages
from West Africa to Mecca starting
around 11th century the pilgrims are not
only royal pilgrims they are also
ordinary men and women ordinary men and
women who who fit on foot they work
their way most of them never get there
or if they get there and they never get
back somewhere along the way they work
and they stay put historians estimate
that by the end of the 19th century
anywhere above sorry minimum 30% 30% of
the population of Darfur are immigrants
from West Africa 30%
the Fukuhara were talking of these
special estates this special Acorah who
gets them the Royal slaves who are in
leading positions in the army and in
administration the holy men the Fukuhara
when they get these landed estates with
full exemptions they pass on the
exemption to their followers which
encourages further emigration it is this
estate system which is the basis of the
Sufi Brotherhood in Sudan the Sufi
Brotherhood which is kind of quasi
sovereign in a way not sovereign strong
word but autonomous
the Sufi Brotherhood is a semi secular
institution semi secular in the sense
that it is autonomous but it has no
aspirations for political power
it remains independent of political
power and the political power the
Sultanate respects this independence but
knowing that the independence is a
guarantee of its own power
because secularism means secularism is
said to be independence but it's really
means going along with whoever is the
power that's second right if you oppose
it you compromise secularism if you
support it you don't that's that's the
deal secularism is a deal whereby the
state dictates the boundary and the only
the terms of the relationship between
the religious in the secular so this is
the new elite of Darfur it's a new a
litre of Darfur the Sultanate its wealth
its expansion is based on a long
distance trade which is firstif and for
most trade in slaves secondly trade in
camels ostrich feathers gold and then
there's internal trade ivory
the Sultanate collapses at the beginning
of the 20th century sorry no collapses
late 19th century collapses late 19th
century because the slave trade
collapses because the slavery Raiders on
horses are defeated by the slave Raiders
with guns because the 19th century sees
a phenomenal expansion of the slave
trade in this part of Africa as
Plantation slavery is introduced in two
colonies in the Indian Ocean it's
introduced from Americas into French
colonies seashells
Avellino and with a phenomenal expansion
now for slaves not only from the state
but now from the market come European
slaving companies Darfur collapses
the new power the new power which in
this history is known as tortilla
tortilla comes in conquers the kingdom
of funds 1821 I think this it's called
to care but that's a misnomer cook
turkey doesn't exist state of Turkey
it's it's Ottoman its Ottoman power but
with increasingly with Egyptian and
English connections more and more
English the turkey herb Ottoman power
which gradually becomes a melange of
Ottoman Egyptian increasingly English
still care begins by an assault on
established centers of power all tribal
centers of power are under assault the
only section of the old elite which
remains is the holy man
the foo Kura and it's not a surprise
that the resistance tutor Kia is led by
the holy man the resistance to folk aura
comes from two centers from around the
Nile Valley from where comes the Mahdi
and from Darfur from the West Darfur and
Kordofan from where comes his deputy
Khalifa Abdullah
the Mafia the massive Marty means what
the savior Abrahamic religions are full
of this notion of a savior who will
arrive in and at that period which is
the end of the Islamic century West
Africa which is under assault by British
troops in and the rumor spreads that the
money is going to appear in the East
masses of people migrate to Sudan
waiting for the Marty sure enough the
Marty appears the son of a boatman on
the Nile the Medea is a very
contradictory phenomenon contradictory
in the sense it's politically
emancipatory and socially reactionary
and let me describe this a little bit
politically the Medea targets the Empire
the success of the mathy shakes centers
of empire London Paris Istanbul
astonished when Gordon comes is killed
British troops are defeated the mafia
rules for over a decade
the British had brought Gordon from
China Chinese Gordon he was called fresh
from successes in China then they bring
in another outstanding champion of the
Empire Kitchener when Kitchener defeats
the Matthews army Marty dies the year
the Mafia wins Khalifa Abdullah heads
the Mafia the state maddie is buried in
the twin city of Khartoum under man
above his tomb is a mausoleum
when Kitchener captures on Du Monde he
breaks the mausoleum desecrates the tomb
brings out the remains of the Maddy
severs the head from the skeleton throws
the skeleton in the Nile puts the head
on his desk as an inkpot the Marty has
reduced the Empire and all its
pretensions to this act it's not unusual
for empires on the defensive to become
obviously uncivil well the Mafia manages
to put together this force but the Mafia
is also extremely brutal against those
who refuse to join it the Brotherhood's
the Sufi Brotherhood's of Sudan divided
into two those around the Nile
who drew their inspiration from Egypt
look at Egypt as part of the ruling
power part of this coalition Ottoman
England Egypt - here they support the
turkey those who draw their inspiration
from West Africa the division is too
neat the mati after all came from the
Nile but it does make some sense of what
was at stake
so the brutality of the violence against
those who don't join at the same time
the socially reactionary aspect so that
even though the Medea talks of equality
within this notion of equality there are
very fixed notions of the role of men
women children and these notions will be
put into practice with force if
necessary in my view this combination of
politically progressive and socially
reactionary movements is a very common
combination through the third world as
we come to the period of decolonization
and anti-imperialism
when the British come back when the
Mafia is defeated they're faced with the
question of order how to establish order
the British Civil Administration the
colonial state they established goes
through three phases the first phase is
a military phase a period of
pacification a highly centralized phase
of individual British officers involved
in centralized rule and they divide the
Brotherhood's the Sufi Brotherhood's
into the midea and the UH Tamiya Tamiya
is the pro Egyptian but then Egypt is
changing Egypt is changing a nationalist
movement is born in Egypt Egypt is no
longer just the King Egypt is also a
nationalist movement against the king
and that movement affects the hitomi ax
when British create a college when they
let in Sudanese into the lower ranks of
the army they confined this recruitment
to the hitomi but now the recruits from
the hot Amir are influenced by the
nationalist movement in Egypt in 1924 a
rebellion happens in Sudan called the
white flag rebellion led by a southern
Sudanese a Dinka junior officer and
that's the turning point is the turning
point at which the British now go
through a five-year brainstorming
process there are extremely interesting
documents they go through a five-year
brainstorming process on how to deal
with this problem they decide to seal
off the South closed districts ordinance
and seal off parts of Darfur and they
begin with a new system in direct rule
it's that system which everything else
is introduction now this is this is the
main point that system that I want you
to get that system in the
that rule the British decide to retry
belies therefore remember the Sultanate
of Darfur is not a tribal affair it's
not a tribal affair the four are a third
West African immigrants are another
third the other third are a host of
ethnic groups even the elite of the
Sultanate of Darfur is not from one
ethnic group the military elite the
administrative elite is derived mainly
from the slaves of the south coming from
different ethnic groups but all lumped
together known as fur teeth the holy men
the Fukuhara
are mainly from West Africa the traders
are mainly from the Nile
it's a multinational cosmopolitan elite
colonial power will create out of this
multinational cosmopolitan elite and
multi-ethnic population a tribe alized
power and a tribe alized society what
does it mean what does it mean to create
a tribe alized power and a tribe alized
society it means the following things
it means first of all an administrative
change whereby the whole of that fall
will be administratively I mean it looks
like New York it's not quite a grid but
administrative Lea will be divided into
different tribal homelands dar dar is
tribal homeland dar is an Arabic word
its meaning before the colonial period
is not tribal homeland its meaning is
homeland and homeland can be anything
homeland is a location it can be the
place where you live it can be the
village you live in it can be the
locality you live in it can be the
country you live in any location it has
multiple meanings but with colonial
power dar will come to mean tribal
homeland not any other homeland tribal
homeland why because this system will
have certain features
the tribes living in Adar will be
divided one of them will be designated a
native tribe an indigenous tribe and the
others will be designated settler tribes
immigrant tribes your rights will depend
on whether you are designated native or
settler it doesn't matter if you are
tenth Denner ation fifth generation
whatever doesn't matter if you're an
immigrant tribe your children are
immigrants grandchildren
great-grandchildren everybody's your
rights will depend on whether you are
designated as native or immigrant what
are the rights the key rights one land
in this retry belies Darfur there is no
hakura or there's only one kind of Akua
there is no special hakura
no hakura which is equivalent to
individual property the only property is
tribal property and tribal property is a
customary right of the native tribe if
you are if you are designated as a
member of a settler or immigrant tribe
you cannot access land as a customary
right to access land you must pay
tribute to the customary Authority
that's the first right right for native
tribes discrimination against non native
tribes second right has to do with
governance
all disputes are solved by a native
authority or native assemblies if you
are born in Darfur of a settler or
immigrant tribe you are involved in a
dispute that dispute the resolution of
that dispute will not involve you or
your representative it will be settled
by a native Authority or a native
assembly so the two are joined land and
participation in the public sphere land
and governance this is a system of
discrimination and privilege privilege
for those designated native
discrimination against those not
designated native on the landscape of
Darfur this system will discriminate
against pastoralists as opposed to
peasants but there are two kinds of
pastoralists in Darfur therefore is like
you know in the in the middle is this
mountain range double-murder it's about
75 miles mountain range to the south you
have savanna grassland and to the north
you have sort of semi desert and desert
so you have two kinds of parcels in the
north are camel pastoralists in the
south are cattle pastoralists cattle
graze camels don't graze they forage
right on trees there's nothing on the
ground it's the trees the cattle
pastoralists in the south are semi
nomads they have villages women and
children stay in these villages the men
go out seasonally with the cattle they
graze the cattle they come back
the cattle nomads are discriminated
against in the sense that their DAR is
limited to where they have villages not
where they graze but the camel nomads
have no villages they are on the move in
a year they move a thousand kilometers
from the north down south so in this
system the camel nomads have no DAR one
section of the population which has no
tribal homeland you can see that the
system is set up to explode
once the external conditions are right
it will explode it will explode because
in any crises those without a dar will
be its first victims and the crisis
comes the crisis comes from the 1960s
onwards as the rains fail it's 20 years
before the rains come back to the
original cycle in the 80s the crisis
also comes because there's a civil war
in Chad a 30-year long civil war because
Chad is like kevo in eastern Congo I
mean that fool is like you in eastern
come in the sense that if you go to
Central Africa
anybody who loses in Rwanda goes to here
in central Congo you organize your arm
when you're ready you come back to run
that's there for anybody who loses in
Chad comes to Darfur they're armed in
Darfur they organize in Darfur they are
ready they go the government in power
bombs Darfur sends in militia soldiers
in
therefore the chase opposition militia
right by the 1990s
Darfur has no water but it's flooded
with arms a clashing cough is $40 in the
marketplace by the time you come to 2003
and the violence of 2003 2004 Darfur
hasn't been in the midst of a crisis for
at least a decade of violence
when you come to the crisis of 2003 2004
and now I I call on your memory and
imagination the word Janjaweed you know
it all right
Janjaweed the perpetrators of this
horrific violence on civilian groups who
are the gender be the core groups among
the Jinja we'd come from two groups one
of the camel nomads of the north those
who have knowed are those who have been
pushed down south by the expanding
encroaching desert who have no homeland
and who say that this notion of the land
being the property of a tribe is not a
notion we subscribe to we subscribe to
the notion that land belongs to the
nation the other group in the Janjaweed
are refugees from Chad who also have no
dahhh who have also been driven by the
drought and the violence my point is
simply to direct your attention to them
to how power gets reorganized in the
colonial period how that reorganization
distinguishes between two kinds of
ethnic groups native and non-native with
relative privileges for the native group
and discrimination against the
non-native group so that with any crises
the conflict is bound to take on an
ethnic form the point is of course
African notions of ethnicity are much
older than colonialism much much older
but the politicization of ethnicity at
its heart was a colonial project that's
the point I would like you to keep in
mind